[Musik]
ende des wartens der korona impfstoff
wird in deutschland verteilt früher als
erwartet laufen bereits erste impfungen
an
viele fragen offen
nach dem mutmaßlichen anschlag in
nashville ermittelt das fbi kultur in
der krise wie theater und kunst unter
pandemie bedingungen überleben können
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen am
zweiten weihnachtsfeiertag auch norbert
könig ist dabei für den sport in circa
zehn minuten sehr gerne genommen ein
knappes jahr ist vergangen seit uns dass
corona virus erreicht hat doch jetzt
soll es besiegt werden mit der bisher
größten impfaktion jemals daran wollen
in deutschland zwei drittel teilnehmen
eine zahl die auf eine rückkehr zum
normalen leben hoffen lässt in
halberstadt im harz sind überraschend
schon heute die ersten in einem
pflegeheim geimpft worden
startpunkt der kampagne ist belgien das
feuerwerk bei entwerten
von dort aus wurden heute zehntausende
dosen des biontech pfizer impfstoffs
nach deutschland geliefert 9750 pro
bundesland bremen erhielt rund 5000
dosen morgen dann der bundesweite im
staat zunächst mit mobilen teams
alexander fertig berichtet ein piekser
soll den schutz bringen vor corona die
101 jährige edith co sala ist die erste
in deutschland gegeben wird
bewohner und beschäftigte in diesem
altersheim in halberstadt bekomme die
injektion einen tag vor dem offiziellen
start
die lang ersehnten kühltransporter mit
dem impfstoff passieren am frühen morgen
die deutsch belgische grenze von der
polizei bewacht wie ein staatsgast und
so wird er in düsseldorf auch begrüßt
nrw-ministerpräsident armin laschet
musste wie die gesamte politik in bund
und ländern grundrechte einschränken
handel und gastronomie schließen im
kampf gegen die pandemie jetzt endlich
mal gute nachrichten
diese erste menge geht in gleicher
größenordnung in alle 16 deutschen
bundesländer geht aus dem ort fürs in
belgien in die gesamte europäische union
auch das ein schönes signal an diesem
tag dass es keinen impfstoff
nationalismus keinen wettbewerb wer
kriegt denn welche mengen gegeben hat
der biontech impfstoff wird auf minus 70
grad gekühlt transportiert dann erst zu
einzelnen impfdosen aufbereitet ab
morgen ziehen bundesweit mobile teams
los um zunächst bewohner und personal in
altenheimen und krankenhäusern zu impfen
die details regeln die einzelnen
bundesländer die hoffnung sie überall
dieselbe es ist ein anfang stand heute
wenn weitere aussichtsreiche zulassungen
erfolgen können wir es schaffen bereits
mitte des jahres mit dem impfen in die
fläche zu gehen und geben der will ein
impfangebot zu machen
mit jeder impfung steigt die hoffnung
auf ein ende der chor ohne
einschränkungen
zumal bislang kaum anzeichen für schwere
nebenwirkungen beobachtet wurden und nun
der tägliche blick auf die aktuellen
corona zahlen
das robert koch institut registrierte 14
1455 neue infektionen innerhalb eines
tages weitere 240 menschen starben in
verbindung mit dem virus
allerdings wird an weihnachten weniger
getestet und viele gesundheitsämter
melden testergebnisse erst nach den
feiertagen
russland steht mit demonstrativer
gelassenheit durch die pandemie
dabei sind die infektionszahlen hoch
mehr als drei millionen menschen haben
sich mittlerweile mit dem virus
angesteckt auch heute melden die
behörden wieder fast 30.000 neue
infektionen und 567 tote und das sind
nur die offiziellen zahlen
seit anfang dezember wird im großen stil
geimpft doch viele sind skeptisch aus
moskau axel sturm
vorgespräch beim imf arzt für julia
natur oscar ist klar sie lässt sich
impfen wir treffen sie in moskau in
einem der 70 impfzentren die skepsis
gegenüber sputnik wie russlands
impfstoff gegen kopf 19 kann sie nicht
verstehen
natürlich ist das ein neuer impfstoff
aber er ist doch eine weiterentwicklung
ich vertrauen unseren ärzten und den
wissenschaftlern frau autor oskar leidet
an einer krebserkrankung auch deshalb
gibt es für sie zum peaks keine
alternative rund zwei drittel der russen
aber sieht das anders ich werde das
nicht machen
ich habe gehört man bekommt vor einer
davon und das sputnik viele
nebenwirkungen hat sputnik klar mache
ich habe mich schon angemeldet
über die möglichen nebenwirkungen des
impfstoffes übrigens gibt es noch keine
offiziellen aussagen die
infektionszahlen unterdessen sind
alarmierend allein in moskau stecken
sich täglich rund 7500 menschen an
wissenschaftler die offen sprechen sagen
sogar ich denke dass diese zahl noch
höher ist die schätze man muss die
offiziellen angaben mit zehn
multiplizieren
sicher ist besser dürfte es erst einmal
nicht werden bald nämlich kommen das
neujahrs und das orthodoxe
weihnachtsfest da wird es viele feiern
viel kontakt geben elena to rock ska
jedenfalls ist froh geimpft zu sein und
nun zu einer tat die in den usa große
unsicherheit und ebenso großes
rätselraten ausgelöst hat die gewaltige
explosion gestern in nashville
erst gab es waren durchsagen per
lautsprecher einen countdown
dann erschütterte eine heftige
detonation die straße mindestens drei
menschen wurden verletzt als das
wohnmobil explodierte mitten in der
innenstadt von nashville im
us-bundesstaat tennessee
möglicherweise aber gab es auch einen
toten noch sind viele fragen offen das
fbi ermittelt peter theißen
großes rätselraten am tag nach der
explosion von nashville wer steckt
dahinter
warum kam eine viertelstunde vor der
schweren explosion eine warnende stimme
aus dem wohnmobil ein countdown bis zur
detonation
die herbeigeeilte polizei beginnt sofort
mit der evakuierung kurz danach passiert
ist
wir warten auf und hörten die schreie
und das geheul der sirenen die
polizisten kümmerten sich nicht um sich
selbst sondern nur um die einwohner von
nashville
sonst würden wir hier nicht über trümmer
hafen reden sondern über menschen leben
amerika feiert nun das kleine
weihnachtswunder von nashville da es nur
drei verletzte gab
inzwischen wurde allerdings menschliches
gewebe am tatort gefunden das fbi
ermittelt die heftigkeit der explosion
deutet darauf hin dass keine amateure am
werk waren
der kauf von kommerziellem oder
militärischen sprengstoff ist in den usa
stark reguliert man kann nicht so
einfach in einen laden laufen und eine
kiste tnt oder dinner mit kaufen
doch immer noch sind die hintergründe
völlig unklar
nashville jedenfalls wurde mitten ins
herz getroffen dieser angriff auf unsere
stadt sollte am tag des friedens und der
hoffnung chaos und angst verbreiten aber
die bewohner nashville haben immer
bewiesen dass die seele unserer stadt
nicht zerstört werden kann
die explosion von nashville hält die usa
in atem
ausgerechnet an weihnachten für papst
franziskus und gläubiger auf der ganzen
welt geht ein ungewöhnliches
weihnachtsfest zu ende fast ohne gäste
dafür mit masken und abstand der papst
erinnerte heute beim angelus-gebet an
verfolgte christinnen und christen
weltweit
die zeremonie wurde corona bedingt aus
der bibliothek des apostolischen
palastes übertragen
der petersplatz blieb auch heute
menschenleer
zum jahreswechsel ist in berlin
eigentlich immer viel los nicht zuletzt
das umfangreiche kulturangebot lockt
tausende in die hauptstadt
ob friedrichstadtpalast
vater oder die philharmonie dieses jahr
ist das natürlich anders
nadia nasa berichtet wie kleine und
große bühnen mit der krise umgehen und
worauf sie im nächsten jahr hoffen
es ist still auf europas größter revue
bühne sonst lockt der berliner
friedrichstadtpalast mehr als eine halbe
million fans pro jahr in seine shows
dann sieht das hier so aufwendige
vorstellungen mit eigenem ballett und
künstlern aus aller welt jetzt ist
intendant berndt schmidt ziemlich allein
im haus die verluste seit märz
gigantisch kann grob sagen dass der
britische palast in diesem jahr etwas
über 20 millionen euro umsatz verloren
hat und das sind natürlich zahlen die
sind schwer zu verdauen
deswegen dass es jetzt noch einen gegen
die zeit alle berliner bühnen sind auf
staatliche nothilfen angewiesen und auf
neue wege den kontakt mit dem publikum
zu halten virtuelle proben im theater
discounter bei einer kleinen bühne in
berlin mitte ende januar wollen sie hier
uraufführung feiern
aber auch die wird es nur im netz geben
hat es voll und schwer
schon letztes jahr war ich erfüllt von
der angst ist wir alle
man muss nur schauen dass es nicht auf
kosten dieses wir sind zusammen in einem
raum wir sind wir haben einen sohn
zusammen einen gefühl einer energie mit
den zuschauern das dass man das nicht
dass man ist sich das nicht völlig
abgewöhnt auch bei den berliner
philharmonikern bleiben die
zuschauerränge bis auf weiteres leer
einmal die woche und auch an silvester
spielt das orchester für das online
portal lukrative tourneen fallen aus wie
überall
natürlich hat das riesen auswirkungen
auf die ganze musik szene auf die
kulturelle vielfalt also auch mit blick
in die zukunft sorgen wir uns natürlich
jetzt auch wir einfach die ganzen
auswirkungen der pandemie sein werden
es war ein katastrophales jahr für die
kulturszene
jetzt hoffen alle auf ein besseres 2021
die fußball bundesliga hat kurz
winterpause aber in der englischen
premier league geht es schon wieder
weiter in arbeit oder ja das ist der
preis der boxing day also bei uns der
zweite weihnachtsfeiertag und der ist in
england traditionell ein football day in
dem sich heute die beiden verfolger von
spitzenreiter liverpool leicester city
und manchester united weihnachtlich
schiedlich friedlich mit 2 2 getrennt
haben
ein hart erkämpftes unentschieden im
verfolgerduell das erste in dieser
saison für leicester dass nach 22
minuten zunächst zurücklegt rennsport
mit der führung für manchester united
nach einer guten halben stunde gleicht
waren sehenswert aus eins zu eins in der
zweiten halbzeit die gäste durch den
zehnten saisontreffer von fernandez
wieder vorne
doch in der schlussphase ist war die da
bester torschütze der vergangenen
premier league spielzeit der 2 2
endstand
letzter in der tabelle bei einem spiel
mehr weiter einen punkt vor manchester
united auf platz zwei aber drei zähler
hinter liverpool folk weltmeister karl
geiger ist von bundestrainer stefan
horngacher für die vierschanzentournee
nominiert worden
ob er nach seiner krone infektion
allerdings schon zum auftakt im
heimatlichen oberstdorf an den start
gehen darf was entscheidet sich morgen
vormittag in 80 tagen um die welt oder
ein bisschen schneller einhand segler
boris herrmann hat sich bei der vendée
globe im südpolarmeer inzwischen in der
spitzengruppe etabliert ungewöhnlich
wenn dich der stille ozean am ersten
weihnachtstag 17 knoten schnell
auf der explorer durch den südpazifik
ungewöhnlich auch dieses buch am bug
duell um platz drei 15 tausend seemeilen
nach regatta statt
der könig schule kam kurz setzt sich
hermann vor dem wollen die veteran auf
den dritten platz bevor ihm der franzose
kam heute wieder überholt vorne jannik
bester wen ebenfalls frankreich boris
herrmann starker vierter kurs weiter auf
kap horn vom weihnachtsbaum ist
vielleicht ein bisschen gemütlicher ja
für mich auf jeden fall
wir blicken noch mal fast 2000 jahre in
die vergangenheit nach pompey wo
archäologen eine art antiker imbissbude
ausgegraben haben
der ausbruch des vesuvs die zeit in der
snackbar angehalten wie die forscher sie
nennen wein römische köstlichkeiten und
eine speisekarte werden jetzt ausgiebig
begutachtet alles konserviert von asche
und lava
sieht toll aus zum wetter in nord westen
wird es stürmisch und regnerisch
oberhalb von 400 metern schneit es
zu den aussichten gleich mehr von
gunther tiersch so viel von uns für den
moment die nächsten nachrichten sehen
sie am späteren abend um 23 uhr 45 ihnen
noch einen schönen und gemütlichen
weihnachtsabend bis morgen um 19 uhr
[Musik]
unheimliche zuschauer sonne regen schnee
und auch sturm deutschland ist
vielfältig wir haben ein massives
sturmgebiet vor allem hierbei islam das
zieht weiter nach süden bringt uns das
sturmfeld nach deutschland und
gleichzeitig auch diese regen und schnee
frau zumindest im westen und norden ja
heute nacht wird erst mal leicht regnen
hier an der nordsee im nordwesten immer
dazu nimmt der wind zu der südwind wird
stürmisch in dieser nacht und im osten
und süden wird es frostig teilweise über
den schnee flächen an den alpen minus 14
grad und morgen behalten wir den
dauerfrost wieder vor allen dingen in
bayern sonst geht's rauf auf drei bis
sieben am oberrhein bis 8 grad
es wird ein stürmischer tag in
norddeutschland stürmische böen sturmböe
den mittelgebirgen orkanböen aus dem
süden die an der nordsee dazu im
nordwesten der regen und oberhalb von
400 meter in den mittelgebirgen schneit
es ihm dann auch anfangs ist es auf
jeden fall im osten und süden noch
ziemlich sonnig ja die aussichten es
wird dann bei uns wechselhaft weiter
gehen bis zum mittwoch immer mal wieder
schnee aber eben nur auf den bergen
oberhalb von 400 metern
ich wünsche einen schönen abend und
machen sie es gut